llevan tres semanas casi acampando en
una plaza al costado de la asamblea
nacional francesa mientras al interior
los diputados discuten y votan el
proyecto de la ley del clima
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esta ley ha sido desacreditada por todos
los organismos por el cese consejo
económico social y ambiental por el
consejo por el clima y las ongs porque
toca a todos los temas de los que
deberíamos ocupar los alojamiento
desplazamiento alimentación pero no
vamos tan lejos lo que debería ser
necesario si queremos responder a la
urgencia del cambio climático
durante esta semana los jóvenes a
quienes se les prohibió manifestar
incluso durante algunos días han
recibido la visita de una veintena de
diputados que yo encuentro muy
interesante que cada uno pueda venir e
intercambiar su punto de vista en esta
discusión parlamentaria hay temas que
están completamente ausentes del bosque
hablamos poco de los ríos poco de los
fletes en tren poco
muchas de esas proposiciones de los
ciudadanos no fueron retomadas había
muchas para desarrollar la práctica de
la bicicleta en la ciudad y reducir los
automóviles
los activistas lamentan también que el
texto haya dejado fuera medidas como el
veto a la publicidad de productos
contaminantes u otras para mejorar el
aislamiento energético de los edificios
así como la prohibición de viajes en
avión que puedan hacerse en tren en no
más de cuatro horas y media si hablamos
del contenido de la ley del clima este
movimiento no ha cambiado las cosas no
hemos cambiado el curso de la historia
pero si hablamos de democracia y
dinamismo de la democracia estamos
teniendo un verdadero éxito el voto de
la asamblea tendrá lugar en mayo con la
mayoría oficialista en el parlamento el
texto está de antemano aprobado